[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre cette suite week-end nous
allons parler actualités mais aussi
loisirs d'ailleurs voici les titres de
ce vendredi 5 février
l'actualité c'est la fin de la
circulation en un terreau fil pour les
motards en ile de france terminé cette
pratique depuis le 1er février
c'était une expérimentation lancée en
2016 alors bonne ou mauvaise chose
nous en débattrons avec nos deux invités
jean ipti de l'association prévention
routière et luc lepeltier de la
fédération française des motards en
colère
nous vous proposerons aussi les idées
sorties et loisirs de célia gars de son
gros avec de la musique est une activité
do it yourself à faire à la maison
enfin comme chaque semaine vincent
couronne créateur du site internet les
surligneurs décrypte les déclarations
des personnalités publiques et
politiques
aujourd'hui il décryptera la gratuité
des transports mesure phare du programme
d'audrey pulvar tête de liste pour la
gauche aux élections régionales en île
de france et aussi le résumé de la
semaine juste avant cela le premier
ministre et plusieurs membres du
gouvernement ont tenu hier soir jeudi 4
février une conférence de presse
même si c'est les chiffres sont
relativement stables
la situation reste particulièrement
fragile le confinement n'est toujours
pas écartée il sera utilisé en tout
dernier recours en cas d'aggravation de
la situation
jean castex a rappelé les mesures
annoncées vendredi dernier la fermeture
des frontières excepté pour les
déplacements essentiel la nécessité de
présenter un test pcr négatif pour
entrer sur le territoire français pour
les ressortissants de pays européens ou
encore la fermeture des centres
commerciaux enfin le chef du
gouvernement a aussi insisté sur le
recours au télétravail impératif pour
les entreprises lorsque la pratique est
possible également dans l'actualité le
conseil départemental des yvelines s'est
réuni ce vendredi 5 février au matin
deux délibérations notamment été votée
la première 15 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour soutenir les
commerçants et artisans yvelinois face à
la crise sanitaire
en juin 2001 le département avait déjà
versé 2,8 millions d'euros
47 communes les yvelines font donc
évoluer le dispositif en élargissant
notamment l'éligibilité à toutes les
communes des yvelines en augmentant le
plafond des aides pour les bars
restaurants et hôtels de 7000 à 10000
euros également en créant un forfait à
destination de nouvelles activités
environ 260 établissements sont
concernés comme les salles de sport
agences de voyages et salles de
spectacles ou encore en laissant chaque
commune classée la liste des
établissements en fonction d'un critère
de priorisation la deuxième délibération
votée ce vendredi matin c'est
l'acquisition d'une parcelle pour la
création d'une maison médicale
territoriales à plaisir ce futur
établissement de 927 mètres carrés sera
implanté en périphérie du centre
hospitalier à proximité de la gare des
commerces et du quartier du val hibou la
structure accueillera à son ouverture
douze professionnels de santé
coût global de l'opération pour le
département un peu plus de 3,8 millions
d'euros
[Applaudissements]
l'actualité de la semaine c'était aussi
l'annnonce de la fin de la circulation
inter files une expérimentation débuté
en février 2016 depuis lundi 1er février
2021 dernier les motos et scooters n'ont
plus le droit de circuler entre les
voitures une infraction désormais
passibles de 135 euros d'amande et de la
perte de trois points sur le permis de
conduire cette pratique avait été
autorisée le 1er février 2016 à titre
d'expérience dans plusieurs départements
dont ceux en ile de france trois mille
kilomètres de routes
au total le résultat de cette
expérimentation ne serait pas concluants
pour parler de ce sujet jean yves petit
bonsoir vous êtes directeur
départemental yvelines de l'association
prévention routière également avec nous
luc lepeltier bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
coordinateur de l'antenne yvelines de la
fédération française des motards en
colère d'abord luc lepeltier en tant que
motard pensez vous que cette
interdiction va être respecté par les
deux ruf
très bonne question personnellement mais
j'irai moi pour moi non je peux pas me
prononcer pour l'ensemble des moteurs
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que cette
circulation inter files n'existe pas
d'hier elle est pratiquée de façon
continuelle depuis vit depuis très
longtemps elle et elle est instaurée
dans dans la circulation urbaine et je
ne pense pas que la plupart des motards
pour où je dis bien pourront respecter
l'interdiction de l'intérêt fil pour
vous cette circulation inter files a
commencé avant finalement le début de
l'expérimentation le 1er février 2016
elle existait deux façons on va dire
entre rim et anarchique puisqu'elle
était interdite et elle est de nouveau
interdite
mais quand on voit le flot de la
circulation aujourd'hui et sa création
urbaine
il est il est difficile d'imaginer que
chaque deux roues motorisés puisse
s'intercaler entre deux véhicules
automobiles camions ou autobus entre
deux maux il faut boire pouvoir choisir
le moindre
et je pense que circuler derrière chaque
chaque véhicule une moto et une voiture
d'abord ça va allonger le flou le flot
de circulation et ça mettra aussi en
danger les motos pour d'autres raisons
alors jean yves petit selon le rapport
du centre expertise sur les risques
l'environnement et la mobilité qui était
en charge d'évaluer cette expérience
l'accidentalité des deux roues motorisés
a augmenté de 12% sur les routes
concernées elles auraient baissé de 10%
sur les autres routes ces accidents
mortels ont également été recensés sur
les routes concernées
que pensez vous de ces chiffres jean
yves petit alors déjà tout d'abord je
dois dire que nous sommes déçus des
résultats de cette expérimentation comme
tout le monde un peu et comme la
déléguée interministérielle elle même
d'après son son communiqué de presse
donc c'était souvent parce que la mesure
semblait bonne maintenant quant aux
chiffres
je dois dire qu'ils sont pas faciles à
analyser la déléguée interministérielle
le dit elle-même ce sont des données
relativement faible et par facile à
analyser et il ya des résultats quand
même assez surprenant que j'avoue moi je
ne m'explique pas je sais pas si
quelqu'un est capable de les expliquer
il ya un département dans lequel sa très
largement augmentée d'un autre dans
lequel s'est très largement baissé donc
ce sont des chiffres qu'il faut prendre
avec prudence surtout qu'il ne concerne
que les deux années et 2016 2018 il n'ya
pas 2019 et a fortiori 2020 mais 2020
évidemment on peut en tirer aucune
conclusion d'une façon générale
évidemment donc ces chiffres sont à
prendre un peu avec avec prudence quels
sont pour vous les effets négatifs comme
positif de cette circulation en un
terreau fils jean-yves petit alors moi
je suis pas motard mais des effets
négatifs
j'en vois pas à vrai dire je voyais
surtout les effets positifs comme l'a
dit luc lepeltier c'est une pratique
existait depuis longtemps et on comprend
bien pourquoi les motards le fond si
pour aller pour éviter les
embouteillages et et circuler plus vite
ça part et ça paraît naturel et sain à
vrai dire si cet encadré
ce qu il est à noter quand même que
d'après l'étude les accidents qu'il y a
eu pour la plupart enfin dans cette
circulation inter files sont des des
motards qui n'ont pas respecté les
règles
donc à partir de là s'ils respectent pas
les règles effectivement ils prennent
des risques
mais là moi je voyais personnellement
que les avantages 7 à cette circulation
inter files vous êtes du même avis
justement luc lepeltier en tant que
motard ah oui tout à fait je partage
l'avis monsieur monsieur petit
comme je le disais heures entre deux
mots choisis on va choisir le moindre et
si on peut encadrer cette circulation
inter files en formant beaucoup mieux
les usagers
je pense que on arrivera à des résultats
positifs par une question pour tous les
deux justement est ce que cette
formation entre guillemets d'être mieux
encadrés
est ce que ce ne serait pas une piste en
tout cas à voir que ce soit a pris dans
les auto-écoles aussi bien pour les
motards que pour les voitures
cette circulation inter files qu'est ce
que vous en pensez vous luc lepeltier
d'abord tout à fait et d'ailleurs c'est
d enseigner dans certaines auto écoles
qui qui sont affiliés à la ffmc donc ces
autos écoles l'enseignent déjà mais je
pense qu'il faut que ce soit généralisé
à l'ensemble des usagers de la route
puisque la ffmc et pour un partage
apaisée de la route et donc si tous les
usagers ils sont conscients des de la
circulation inter files qui puisse être
faite dans des conditions apaisées et
réglementée nous sommes tout à fait
favorables à la circulation inter files
pour vous aussi eu jean yves petit c'est
une piste à a peut-être envisager cette
formation dans les auto-écoles
je dirais même plus que ça je pense que
c'était prévu dès le début tant qu'il
n'y a pas de règle
tant que c'est pas dans le code de la
route on peut pas on peut pas l'enseigné
au sens propre et réglementaires si je
puis dire
à partir du moment où ça sera mis dans
le code de la route là oui forcément ça
sera enseignée dans les auto-écoles
aussi bien pour les motards que pour les
automobilistes
et cette mesure d'après les communiqués
de presse du ministère de l'intérieur
était bien accepté par les par les
automobilistes et par les motards donc
oui
il faut enfin ça serait une très bonne
chose que ce soit enseignée dans les
auto-écoles mais pour ça il faut qu'ils
aient un cadre réglementaire évidemment
merci à tous les deux et on avait une
petite question l'expérimentation
pourrait être reconduit ainsi j'ai bien
compris
tout à fait nous souhaitons que la dde a
promis une nouvelle expérimentation très
prochainement et nous nous
nous souhaitons être associés à cette
nouvelle expérimentation le plus le plus
largement possible
le message est passé en tout cas merci
luc lepeltier merci jean yves petit
lavoir était avec nous sur ce plateau
aujourd'hui et le reste de l'actualité
c'est bixente mais rien senti steban qui
nous la résume en 78 secondes
[Musique]
gérald darmanin a acté un renforcement
des contrôles de 30% après le couvre feu
de 18h le ministre de l'intérieur s'est
rendu dimanche 31 janvier au péage de
buchelay pour assister aux vérifications
des forces de l'ordre
l'élection de trappes annulé le tribunal
administratif a remis en cause le mandat
d'al hira b il lui est reproché d'avoir
utilisé son association coeur de trappes
pour promouvoir son image pendant la
campagne ali rabais a fait appel de la
décision auprès du conseil d'état
tony estanguet président du comité
d'organisation des jeux olympiques 2000
24 est venu à la rencontre des jeunes au
vélodrome nationale pour la semaine
olympique et paralympique
des animations étaient organisées tout
au long de la semaine sur les différents
sites yvelinois des jo de paris
pas de report pour les premières
injections de vaccin c'est ce qu'a
annoncé la rs ile de france cette
semaine
30 2012 pfizer et moderna ont été
commandés pour les yvelines cela
représente environ 3853 dévoue maintenu
les taxis de saint germain en laye ont
été mobilisés pour faciliter les
vaccinations surnommé levac si ce
service gratuit a été mis en place avec
la mairie afin d'amener les personnes
âgées se faire vacciner
enfin la crue de la seine sous
surveillance après avoir été placés en
vigilance orange le week-end du 30
janvier le département est redescendu en
jaune en début de semaine pas de
véritable urgence pour le moment
[Musique]
après cette semaine bien chargée et quoi
de mieux que de se détendre le week-end
comme chaque vendredi c'est lié à 400 go
vous propose ses idées sorties et
loisirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine nous allons parler musique
née à poissy et grandi à achères pendant
sept ans charles kamoun est en lice pour
intégrer la star academy au canada il
lui reste une étape à passer le premier
variété un show en direct sur tva le 14
février prochain
interview express avec ce chanteur
guitariste pour l'instant on ne sait
rien on sait qu'on a des chances on a
préparé je sais qu'il ya des artistes
invités qui vont être présents dont -
corneille whitelock puis si je peux
chanter une chanson et corneille se sont
calmes ont dû savatage est un rêve de
réaliser ça va être un spectacle
incroyable puis que oui j'ai une
fébrilité certainement mais c'est que du
bonheur
[Musique]
on y donne en ce moment dolor c'est
vianney j'adore setec j'adore ça va
j'adore cette musique et tout puis sinon
j'ai grandi avec charles aznavour dans
les oreilles je m'inspire beaucoup de
mon bagage
j'ai une vie assez mouvementée puis je
m'inspire de ça pour écrire mes chansons
je suis inspirée par l'amour également
déçu c'est sûr c'est sur ces soins
d'ailleurs je le dis dans toutes mes
entrevues
la france me manque c'est mes racines
la france a fait partie d'une des plus
belles parties de ma vie mon rêve est de
réussir ma carrière musicale au départ
au québec met ensuite en france à
présent une activité de 8 sur self vous
avez déjà avait découvert des recettes
de lessive ou de dentifrice cette
semaine c'est au tour du produit pour
les lave vaisselle on voit ça avec
mélanie poker bonjour bonjour c'est une
recette très rapide où il faut compter
au moins une dizaine petite dizaine de
minutes pour réaliser une quarantaine de
passer alors on va bien sûr de débuter
avec les ingrédients
vous aurez donc besoin de 200 g de
cristaux dessous de 150 g de
percarbonate de 200 grammes d'acide
citrique et 100 g de growth elle est
bien sûr un petit peu d'eau alors au
niveau des ustensiles un saladier une
cuillère et un bouchon en liège
catherine thomas de l'association vers
gris nous explique les propriétés des
ingrédients le percarbonate 6 1
blanchissant un détachement et un
purifiant et un désodorisant les
cristaux de soude
c'est un nettoyant et un dégraissant et
l'acide citrique ses fins détartrant est
un anti calcaire assez puissant le sel
en et les bactéries également vous
pouvez commencer à mettre les 4 premiers
ingrédients dans le saladier et bien sûr
vous mélangez le tout et la recette peut
aussi s'arrêter là on peut en effet
s'arrêter là on met directement le
mélange dans un pot ce sera de la poudre
tout simple il faut juste un pur bien
étanche pour que ça ne durcissent pas
alors si vous êtes vous optez pour des
pastilles on écoute à nouveau catherine
thomas vous allez prendre votre pape aux
réalisateurs dos et vous allez vaporiser
délicatement à peu près je mets à peu
près 5 pression mais je commence déjà
une première un premier jet et ça fait
tout de suite une réaction on voit que
ça commence à mousser vous mélangez le
foot il faut surtout surtout éviter de
ne pas trop mettre dos puisque vos
pastilles m ont gonflé
ça sera pas ça trappe à l'effet fréty
qu'à partir du moment où ça fait un peu
comme un crumble
vous pouvez les nets en bacs dans votre
bac à glace ou alors une fois cette
étape terminée vous mettez comme l'a dit
catherine thomas le produit dans le bac
à glaçons vous éviter de toucher avec
les mains car les produits peuvent être
irritants il faut sud compact et vos
pastilles et qu'un bouchon de liège une
nuit de séchage dans un endroit sec et
le tour est joué vous obtenez des
pastilles ya eu c'est dans le
compartiment de votre lave vaisselle
merci mélanie pour cette recette de 8
sur 16
[Musique]
chaque vendredi en février des visio
conférences sont proposées par l'office
de tourisme de versailles
nous recevons aujourd'hui sophie hébert
bons joueurs bonjour vous êtes la
directrice générale de l'office de
tourisme de versailles
quelle est la programmation de ces
visioconférence alors nous programmons
celesio conférence tous les vendredis à
15 heures donc c'est un rendez vous
récurrent fx facile à retenir et les
visites fallait les conférences sondés
ont des thèmes différents varier en
fonction dès vendredi bien entendu on
aborde la vie de grands personnages
historiques comme on peut également
parler de sujets beaucoup plus varié
beaucoup plus transversaux des visites
de la ville virtuelle ou encore la
célèbre affaire des poisons qu'on va
pouvoir retrouver
j'ai vu qu'il y avait madame royal
hyacinthe rigaud les biographies sont
sont à l'honneur ainsi je me trompe pas
oui tout à fait nous travaillons avec
une équipe de guides conférenciers qui
développent ces sujets là au cours de
conférences sur site et donc on a trouvé
logique de les transposer en
visioconférence et c'est vrai que l'on
fait la part belle aux personnages
célèbres qu'on a beaucoup de femmes
on va avoir un incroyable comme vous le
disiez on a également madame de
pompadour
on va aborder également l'impératrice
joséphine le 8 mars pour la journée de
la femme et il ya sainte rigaud qui sera
un petit peu plus tard en mars
on a également quelques quelques hommes
avec monsieur le frère de louis xiv qui
sera proposé le 12 février prochain et
d'autres thèmes sont encore à venir pour
le courant du mois de mars
alors pourquoi vous vous proposez c'est
visioconférence alors on propose toute
l'année en temps normal des visites
conférences de la ville de versailles
mais également des conférences en salle
pour un public d'habitués que nous avons
et nous a semblé logique après le
premier confinement de poursuivre cette
programmation par le biais du numérique
c'est quand même plus sympathique et
confortable de suivre une conférence de
son canapé chez soi au chaud et c'est un
thème qui est tout à fait approprié à
une saison hivernale est alors à qui
s'adressent ces visioconférence un
public vraiment très très large en fait
il suffit simplement d'être intéressés
par le thème qui est proposé ça peut
être des défunts ce sont souvent des
adultes mais ça peut également être des
familles avec des enfants ce sera
vraiment très variable en fonction des
sujets comment fait-on pour y participer
alors pour y participer il suffit de
s'inscrire et de réserver son accès en
ligne sur le site versa est tirée
tourisme.com et on vous enverra une fois
votre inscription sera fait un lien de
connexion pour vous connecter le
vendredi donc à 15h et les
visioconférences elle dure combien de
temps elle dure une heure et demie et
d'autres visioconférence sont elles
prévues plus tard
alors on en a pour tout le mois de
février tout le mois de mars également
en fonction des aléas de
sanitaires que nous allons rencontrer
nous les poursuivrons sur le printemps
l'été n'est pas forcément très propice à
ce type de visioconférence mais par
contre je pense qu'on les reprendra très
certainement l'hiver prochain et
dernière question est ce que c'est
important de continuer à créer des
événements culturels
face à la crise sanitaire ah oui c'est
très important
on a une on a une demande en ce sens le
public est demandeur
c'est clair qu'il faut continuer de les
faire rêver les faire voyager d'une
certaine manière de leur apporter un
petit peu de culture chez eux à la
maison et ça permet de passer un peu le
temps parce que c'est vrai quand même en
période de confinement on a forcément
envie de sortir et de se changer les
idées
merci beaucoup ce qui est vert d'avoir
été notre invité mais je vous en prie
avec plaisir
[Musique]
oh
et pour finir cette page loisirs nous
vous proposons une idée de sortie pour
le week end le parc du château de
breteuil à choisey le propose à ses
visiteurs une mise en scène de son et
lumière des contes de perrault de 10h à
19h vous pourrez aussi vous balader dans
le labyrinthe l'air de jeu et le parc
bien sûr qui fait 75 hectares et le 7-8
week end continue avec eléonore pour
parler de l'actualité
[Musique]
comme chaque semaine on retrouve un
journaliste de la rédaction de tv 78 qui
nous présente ce qui fera la une la
semaine prochaine cette semaine
astrid bergère journalistes de la
rédaction est responsable de l'émission
vais y fait bon soir alors vous allez
nous parler de la montée de la seine
dans les yvelines
exactement eléonore 1 cette semaine
vigicrues a passé les yvelines en
vigilance jaune
la selle est monté à cause des dernières
précipitations et d'ailleurs certains
habitants du nord du département se sont
retrouvés les pieds dans l'eau alors la
semaine prochaine et nous reviendrons
sur cet épisode et nous verrons quelles
sont les procédures mises en place face
à ces phénomènes les mairies suivre cela
de près j'imagine oui alors les mérites
d'un des informations très régulièrement
sur les réseaux sociaux est d'ailleurs
plusieurs communes comme mantes-la-jolie
ou poissy ont mis en place leur plan de
sauvegarde communal
c'est à dire que sous la responsabilité
du maire des actions sont planifiés pour
mieux gérer les risques
il est possible par exemple de fermer
l'accès à une route ou un chemin merci
astrid pour toutes ces précisions
et n'oubliez pas de rester vigilant lors
de fortes pluies pour refermer ce 7,8
week end votre rendez-vous en
partenariat avec les surligneurs ce
collectif qui décrypte les déclarations
des personnalités publiques et
politiques
aujourd'hui retour sur la gratuité des
transports mesure phare du programme
d'audrey pulvar tête de liste pour la
gauche aux prochaines élections
régionales d'île de france
on écoute vincent couronne docteur en
droit à l'université versailles saint
quentin et fondateur des surligneurs
la gratuité des transports publics en
ile de france c'était une promesse
d'anne hidalgo candidate à la mairie de
paris
c'est maintenant une promesse de sa
protégée audrey pulvar candidate
socialiste à la présidence de la région
ile de france rejoindrait ainsi
dunkerque montpellier où même les
communes franciliennes de levallois est
plutôt qu'ils ont mis en place des bus
municipaux gratuit en plus du réseau
régional
en 2008 valérie pécresse avait commandé
un rapport sur le coût de cette gratuité
pour la collectivité qui s'élèverait à
2,5 milliards d'euros par an alors
comment financer ce manque à gagner est
bien la candidate
audrey pulvar a la réponse la création
de nouvelles taxes sur les commerces sur
les fortunes immobilières ou encore sur
les transports polluants
alors où est le problème juridique ici
bien juridiquement ça pose problème
parce que c'est un problème qui remonte
en plus de ça à la révolution française
et bien c'est le parlement et lui seul
qui créent les impôts
conséquence la région ne peut pas créer
de nouvel impôt et si elle est élue
audrey pulvar devra demander au
parlement de bien vouloir le faire pour
elle ce qui en l'état actuel des
équilibres politiques
on va pas se mentir est hautement
improbable alors c'est vrai que la
région gère quelques taxes la taxe sur
les cartes grises par exemple dont elle
peut modifier le taux ou encore la tei
cpe main que vous payez à la pompe
mais audrey pulvar précise bien qu'elle
ne veut pas toucher à ces taxes voilà
donc une promesse qui risque de se
perdre en cours de route et de faire une
victime la crédibilité des responsables
politiques
c'est la fin de votre 7,8 week-end merci
de l'avoir suivi l'information revient
lundi à 18h dans le 7-8 journal présenté
par grégory canale et d'ici là je
souhaite une très belle soirée et un
très bon week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]